You can use groups to restrict user access to certain parts of an organisation's infrastructure.
For example, different people have responsibility for operations, finance and payroll applications.
Different people have access to development, staging and production systems.
And different people handle applications in different geographical regions.
By default, groups have no restrictions on sites. However, you can configure a group to be restricted to the sites that are relevant to a group's roles.
For example, you might want to let a group scan results for everything within the production folder, but disallow the HR folder beneath that.
To restrict the group's access to sites, log in to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition as an administrator.
From the team menu, select groups. Select a group from the list or create a new group.
In the site restrictions tab, click the folders, subfolders or sites that you want to restrict access to.
When you're happy with your choices, click save.
Click save.